Hmm.
The black men of the community
could not play hall. He was away.
Hockey teams in the area,
they were just segregated.
We've got some season ticket holders that
are complaining about bringing you here
at to answer everything. All the name
calling the n word. I heard it all.
He got death threats.
You're playing the white man's game.
No, you can compete with the
best gear. The wrong college.
For 12 years we've been coming to hockey
and he's only the second one we've ever
seen.
Was there a discrimination issue or was
it simply a fact that he was too proud
to go to the minor leagues and you
can find good arguments on both sides.
There was racial slurs
every corner.
Only way to get back at him when
race,
like so many other things serve as a
distraction and the minute you allow it to
distract to,
you'll never reach your destination.
It doesn't matter what color you are.
If you want to do something,
you're going to do it and don't let
anybody tell you you can't do that.
Why wouldn't you play basketball or
while you play football? And I'm like,
why can't I play hockey?
What's wrong with it?
Cause when the,
I didn't realize this at that time at
that I have to have real barriers and
open doors.
Big tried to get rid of us.
Our job is to keep building.
You got guys like Wayne Simmons
and Chris Stewards and Dk,
my soul on at Snyder,
you got a dream to be a hockey player
and he wasn't going to let anybody take
that away from him.
They made it so much easier for us to
come up and enter play and to know to not
think about color as as
a, as a factor. You know,
it's just based on our
steel amount on our college
is just given me so many opportunities
and the only reason why I even have that
opportunity is because of that.
Nice.
You owe it to yourself and you're
playing a sport to know your history,
especially if you're black.
Wow.
All right.
I can't begin to tell you how excited
I am to be moderating this panel today.
We've got a, an esteemed group
of panelists on the stage today.
And I'd like to briefly
introduce each of them to you.
And I'm sure each of them have
the opportunity to give them,
give you all a little bit more
color I into who they are.
But on the very far end we've got Kwame
mason who is the director and producer
of soul on ice.
Yeah,
we have living history right
next to him. Mr Willy. Oh sorry.
It was the first black player in the NHL.
We have Anson Carter who
is a former NHL player,
including many teams like the
capitals, Bruins, rangers, local.
Yes. Yup, Yup. And last but not least,
we have Jessica Berman who is the
VP of special projects and uh,
corporate social
responsibility for the NHL.
So amongst other things, certainly we're
going to talk about soul on ice today,
but we're also going to talk about
the evolution of, of the NHL,
particularly as it relates
to, uh, to black folks.
And I will tell you in full
transparency and honesty,
I am not the biggest hockey fan
that sits in front of you. Uh,
I'm a fan of sports overall.
Um,
and I will tell you without
hesitation that, uh, this documentary,
this film opened up an entire new world
for me in not only understanding the
sport, uh, but understanding the evolution
of the sport and understanding, um,
the culture within the sport, but
a even more so than things, uh,
the many things that the NHL is doing
in terms of diversity and continuing to
grow the sport. Uh, overall. So let's go
ahead and start with you upon me and, uh,
talk about a little bit about
more about your background,
but what was the inspiration
for creating this film?
All right, well first of all, it's wanted
to thank Google for having us here.
It's a real honor and I'm really pleased
to be here with these great people who
I've gotten to know,
uh,
over the last couple of years to just
talk about a hockey and, uh, we're,
we're trying to do, to grow
the game. Uh, for myself,
I was a radio announcer for
14 years and I'm in 2005.
I ended up working in
Edmonton, Alberta, Canada,
and a over there over there. It's, it's,
it's like that's just a bed
of hockey. And, um, you know,
I was really fortunate to meet and hang
out with a lot of the Edmonton Oilers
and they would send me to a lot of
games and sitting in the audience,
they're just how beautiful that game
is for those who haven't been to a live
hockey game.
You got to,
you have to go and see one man
because it's just incredible.
And I'm looking at that and looking at
the speed, the athleticism and all that,
and getting to know a
lot of the guys off eyes.
The first thing that came to my mind
was something that I used to think about
when I was a child,
which was,
how come there's still not a lot of
black athletes played hockey. And, um,
you know, in that thinking, I've
thought to myself, you know,
there are, or I was seeing a
lot of young guys coming up.
I was watching answer
Carter. I mean, you know,
I remember sitting in my room watching,
um,
uh, an Olympic game. Uh, and answer
and scoring the winning goal.
I remember how long it took
to get that, that, uh, the,
the referee to call the goal.
And I was just sitting there by myself
and just so happy for him. And, um,
you know,
I would go on my computer and I would
Google a black hockey players and I would
get this list of guys and
I'd be reading these stories.
And then one day I found out about the
colored hockey league of Nova Scotia and
I was at my,
in my thirties at this time,
not really bothered me because here I
am a black Canadian and hockey is our
second language and nobody
taught me about this.
So I started to gather a
lot of information and I
put it aside and I said to
myself, you know, this would be a really
cool documentary one day to talk about,
you know,
black history and hockey.
And so we fast forward to
a 2011 and something really
tragic in my life happened
where my mom had cancer. And I, um,
I remember sitting on her
bed in the hospital and
talking about what I was going
to do in the future because as a mother,
she was very conservative. And I said,
you know,
I got this idea to do this documentary
about hockey players and she just told me
the best advice ever, and she said,
just go for it. So after she passed,
I,
um,
I just cut my head and I put my head
down and I started gathering information,
making some phone calls,
uh,
and trying to do the best I could to
kind of put something like this together.
And so,
you know,
fast forward to 2011 I saw my first
interview and from then on it just kinda
snowballed and it was a loan. Let's talk
about that a little bit more, right?
I mean, first time filmmaker, yes,
I watched the documentary and you're fine
to a bunch and you must have been in a
number of different cities to have
gotten all this done. Um, you know,
was there a funding behind this? Like
how, how did you make this happen?
Well funding was me selling
my condominium, which
in the case, yeah, I would advise that for
any filmmakers out there. But you know,
I was,
I'm so passionate about the sport,
I'm so passionate about black
history and it just was a great mesh.
And you know,
if no one was going to invest in me,
I figured out how to invest in myself
because I thought like nobody was telling
that story. So if I just said,
well, I don't have money right now,
might as well just wait. I Dunno how
long I was going to have to wait. So,
um, and I had already quit my
job, so I had to do something.
So, uh, I had,
I had some capital and I had two great
family back in Toronto and they just
said, do what you gotta do. So I sold my
condominium and then use that money to,
to just kind of help fund going
to different places and uh, yeah.
And again, you know, being
a first time filmmaker,
not necessarily having a name
that's a household name, right.
Getting the likes of Mr
O'ree and some others
to participate. Um, you know,
tell us an easy, it wasn't easy.
I think at the end of the day for me
it was, you know, trust, you know,
I remember talking to Anson on the phone,
you know,
in the early stages and telling him what
I was, what I wanted to do. And you know,
um, George La rock was a great guy that
I had known in Edmonton. So, you know,
he was the first person, one of the
first NHL guys that I was able to shoot.
And then I already shot Mr Herb Carnegie.
And from there I think guys started
to trust and I answer the past man,
I just pestered, I just called
and I called, I called and I,
I mean the first time I met Willie
I just passed it. That's a good
Italian man. I just Kinda, hey listen,
can I interview you?
Hey, can I interview you?
Where are you going to be all
interviewed? And you know, I just,
I literally rolled up on Mr Orion. I
said, I'm going to come to San Diego.
And I went interviewed and the day I
went to San Diego to interview him,
he wasn't even at home.
His wife was at home and she didn't
answer the door and she's calling to some
young guy with the camera equipment
outside and he came home and uh,
we did the film, we did the interview. But
uh, it's just perseverance, which is the,
to me, the theme of the film, which
is perseverance through adversity.
The adversity for me was as a
first time filmmaker, you know,
nobody was going to
give me money for this.
Nobody who is going to just
let me into their homes.
I had to keep persevering and
I had to keep telling them
that, you know, you know,
this is something very
important and I think, you know,
answering those guys can
probably say that. You know,
they saw how serious I was
so they let me have there
to stay on the theme of
perseverance for a moment.
And we're going to go deep dive
with Mr v and just a moment,
but can you give a little
bit of color around,
there was many narratives
in the documentary,
but talk a little bit more about Jane
Lindo and kind of how that was kind of a
bit of an anchor in the, in the uh, he,
he went through some things clearly.
Yeah. Well, you know, I,
I wanted to show our young man that was
going through his last year of the Ohl,
you know, just, you know,
his draft year and there's a couple
of the guys that could have, you know,
really got Josh Hill sang was a
slave to go in the first round.
So that was a big name.
That would be a great story.
But I really wanted to show somebody
that I felt was kind of like an underdog
that was kind of under the radar and
just to see what would happen with them.
And you know, Jaden comes from a
really well established family.
And one of the things I wanted to do was
I wanted to show the black family unit,
you know,
mother,
father and supporting a young kid
because so many times when we see film
narratives,
you always have the broken home.
I wanted to show a complete home and I
wanted to show that hockey is something
that is a very family oriented sport
and you need your family there.
So I thought that their family was a
great unit, had a great story to tell.
And you know, Jason was a great kid
that when I first met up with him,
he was this shy kid and just
throughout the, you know,
the year that I kind of worked with them,
his confidence grew and,
and unfortunately
he had a knee injury but it didn't stop
him from getting drafted at the end.
And he was able to just, you
know, hear his name being called.
And I thought that was very important
to show these young kids that, you know,
you don't have to be the superstar guy,
but as long as you work hard,
somebody is going to recognize that.
That's right. That's right. Perseverance,
perseverance through
adversity. So let's, uh,
let's stay on that theme and we're going
to transition a bit over and speak to a,
uh, a living legend. Mr O'ree, uh,
who in 1958 became the
first black NHL player.
Um, Miss Story, clearly you
were featured in the film. Um,
tell us a little bit about your journey,
your largely and widely recognized
as being the Jackie Robinson of,
of ice hockey, if you will. Um,
tell us a bit about your journey and
then talk a little bit about that
comparison and what,
what that kind of means to you and whether
or not you are in agreement with that
or not.
Well,
well,
I met Jackie Robinson and two occasions.
I met him in 1949 and then
I met him again in 1962.
But, uh, again, um, I was the
youngest of 13 children and, um,
uh, I was, uh, born in Fredericton,
New Brunswick, and, uh,
there were only my older brother
and myself that played hockey. My,
my sister were into basketball and,
um, some other sports. But, uh,
uh, at the age of three,
I started skating, uh, uh,
in my backyard and I started playing
organized hockey at the age of five.
And like all Canadian, uh, boys
and girls, you know, there's,
there's ice all over the place
and I had a rink in my backyard.
I used to escape the school.
Um, then my life was when I was,
um,
when I was 14 years of age,
I decided I wanted to become
a professional hockey player
and thanks to my older
brother who was not only my brother and
my friend, but he, he was my mentor. And,
uh,
when he found out that a,
I wanted to play hockey and hopefully
play professional and then hopefully one
day playing in the national hockey league,
um, he gave me all the support that a,
that a brother could give. So, um,
I left my hometown at a, at 17,
went up to Quebec to play
my first year junior, uh,
with the Quebec Front neck
coach Phil Watson. Um,
was the instructor who played with the
New York Rangers back in the forties. Uh,
that was my first year. My second
year I spent in Kitchener, Ontario,
Canada, um, coach, uh, uh,
Black Jack Stewart. Um, what's the second
coaching then? You know, back then,
none of the players weren't helmets,
no face shields, no face guards.
Goldie's didn't wear any mass
though. You're, you know,
you're facing head was exposed to pucks
and sticks and everything else that was
flying around on the ace. And,
um, when unfortunate accident, uh,
I'm in front of the net,
slapshot a ricocheted the puck come up
and struck me in the right. I hit me flat,
broke my nose, a proud of my cheek, and
I remember dropping down to the ice.
And the next thing I know I'm being
placed in an ambulance and taken to the
hospital. Uh, I'm in my hospital bed.
Dr. Henderson was the surgeon,
uh,
come in and stood by my bedside
in my recovery. Roman said,
Mr [inaudible] says, I'm sorry
to inform you. He says the, uh,
the impact of the puck
complete d shattered the retina
and your right eye and he
says, you're going to be blind and you
will never play hockey again. Well,
I'm 19 years of age and the goals and
dreams that I had set for myself of
playing professional and hopefully
playing in the national hockey league were
gone.
So I laid in my hospital bed and um,
I get out of the hospital and then the
next three days, within the next 10 days,
I'm back on the ice. Um,
practicing and a, and playing.
The only difference I felt about myself,
uh,
I just couldn't see it on my right eye.
Now imagine being a left hand shot and
to playing left wing. So to compensate,
I had to turn my head all the way around
to the right to pick the puck up with
my left thigh. And I was overskating the
puck and missing the net. And I said,
Willie, what's wrong? So I just said,
forget about what you can't see and
concentrate on, but you can see.
So my game started to pick up,
but it started scoring some goals
and now the season's over and uh,
I either have to turn pro the next
and the next season or play amateur.
And I was keeping my
fingers crossed that I,
it would be contacted
by professional team.
So I returned home to my
hometown and punch him luck,
who was the coach and general
manager of the Quebec cases.
The professional team up in Quebec
contacted me and said, well, he says, uh,
I watched you play the last
couple of years. He says,
I'd like to invite you to training camp.
So I went to training camp and uh,
I made the team, but I didn't disclose
the fact that I couldn't see it.
I'm a writer. I never took
an eye exam. So I said,
if you're good enough to make the
team with one eye, he said, don't,
don't worry about it. So I made the team,
uh, we won the championship that year.
That, that's what gave me the extra
confidence that I needed to, um,
to go on and a and play pro hockey.
That is incredible. So, so let me,
not only were you the, he had the,
the kind of weight of being,
you know,
being pulled up with the Bruins. Right,
right after they had some injuries, right.
Being the first black player in the NHL,
you had site only in one
eye this entire time,
which was an additional load on
top of you. A at the same time.
Yes.
I went to the Bruins,
a training camp in two occasions in
1957 and 58 and they didn't take any eye
exams. They were more concerned about
your physical condition. And I always,
I always kept myself in good shape.
I worked out in the summertime
and worked in the gym.
So when I went to training camp,
I was probably one or two pounds a
away from my playing weight. So a,
when they called me up
on January the 18th,
1958 to play two games against
the Montreal Canadians. Um,
when I stepped on the ice that
Saturday night in Montreal, uh,
against the Montreal Canadians,
uh,
and became the first black player to play
in the, in the national hockey league.
It was, it was just a
thrill for me. I had a,
I was no stranger to the Montreal fans
because I had played against a Montreal
junior Canadians in the forum and
played against the Montreal royals,
the professional team in the form.
Um,
when I skated on the ice that
evening, I was just, well,
you'll read what the Bruins Jersey on
and I could see fans pointing it in my
direction and uh, uh, wondering, oh,
we just a black player. You know what,
put the Bruins with number 22.
I can tell you it's hard enough to
play with two good eyes. The national
one is impressive. Listen, I'm, I'm,
I'm trying to put it all together in
my head about how that worked out.
You almost have to like take a day and
just walk around like this and see how
hard that is.
And then the magic day and an hour
with flying projectiles at a 60 miles,
some odd miles an hour. Can we look
back on your professional career,
Mr [inaudible]? Like, can you,
can you recall one particular moment
that was a highlight and maybe one
particular moment that was a low
light for whatever reason? Well,
the highlight was when I first
scored my goal in the, uh,
in the national hockey
league, it was, uh, January,
the first new year's night in Boston
against the Montreal Canadians. Uh,
we're warming up, one of my teammates,
a Bronco Horvath's. I said, well,
if you ever get in on Hodge, uh, keep
the puck Mo. He's weak on low shots,
keep it away from his club. Uh, Jacques
Pont, who was the number one goal?
He was out, uh, and Charlie Hodge
was the backup goalie. So we're,
uh, we're skating around and um, he
says, remember now if you get in low,
low on him.
So it was the third period.
And I remember I had just broken
away from my check and I'm,
I'm busting down the left wing and a
little boy been one of my defenseman just
hit me with a perfect pass. I didn't have
to break stride. So I'm going in on a,
on the defenseman and I go, uh,
get the defensemen out of position.
Now I'm going in on Hodge and I got my
head up and all of a sudden I could hear
this loan,
Willie low wind and shoot the puck.
And it either was right along the ice or
just was off the ice and hit the inside
of the post and went in.
That made it three to one for the Bruins.
And then about seven minutes later,
the honoree the pocket rocket
scored the second goal and uh,
made it three to two. But the goal that
I scored a was the winning goal. And, um,
the Bruins fans gave me a two minute
standing ovation. I'll never forget it.
It was quite an evening. That's
phenomenal. And traps one low,
late if there is one, a low
life. Uh, uh, yes, a little life.
It was my first trip in Chicago.
Um,
one of the, one of the original
teams in the original six.
Um, there was, um, I was warming
up and I won't mention his name,
but one of the players I'm
big right hander came around
and gave me a two hander
rate across the ankles as we're warming
up and he looks up and he's John and
they made a racial remark, but that
didn't bother me. So anyway, the,
the warm ups over,
we come out,
the first period's about minutes
into the first period. There's, um,
I'm in behind the net and I got
the puck and I'd dump it out to a,
my winger and I'm this player come
in and he caught me on my blind side.
I couldn't see him.
And he stuck about six inches out in
his stick and he hit me a split my nose,
not per two front teeth out. And, uh,
my teeth just dropped down in the ice and
now he's just standing there and these
kind of, he made a racial remark, but
that isn't what set me off. He, uh,
he just stood there and smiling. Now he
was about six, three and I was five, five,
eight, five, nine. So I took a,
I took my stick and I hit him
right over the head with it
and I cut in for a number of
stitches and then my, my stick broke.
Now I know we're going to fight.
So I dropped my gloves and he grabbed
the much bigger and he hit me a couple of
times and we'd go back up against the
screen. And the first thing I said,
just hold on when he just hold onto
him so he can hit. Meanwhile the bolts,
benches emptied all the Chicago
Black Hawks come out of their bench.
All the Bruins come out of their bench.
And there was,
there was 92 minutes and penalties
assessed on the players. Now, uh,
I go into the room and they stitched me
up and plug my nose and at least I want
to come back and sit on the bench with
the, with the team. But the coach,
Milt Schmidt, said, Willie,
he says, these, these fans
became so violent that I, I'm,
I'm worried about you
getting Bartling harm.
So I had to stay in the dressing room.
Um,
and they had two police officers
outside the dresses and the whole,
the entire game. Now this was six
minutes into the first period. And, uh,
I stayed in there and
at the first thing I,
I did is I just turned the lights out
and I sat there and I kind of meditated
for a couple of minutes and then I
turned the lights back on and I said, no,
Wiliam says, uh, if you're going to leave
the league, uh, it stopped because some,
some jokers is trying to get you out of,
um,
you have the skills and the ability to
play in the league at that time. So, um,
basically that was opposed the worst one,
the next, the next trip. And it was a,
I'm not as bad,
but I finally gained the respect of not
only in the players on the opposition,
but fans in the stands. That's right.
But you did meet him later on in life.
I met him 30 years later. Um, well
many, but it's the, um, the NHL.
All Star game was in Chicago.
I got an invitation through
the hockey club and uh,
and then they call me on
the phone and I said, well,
why are you inviting me 30
years after I left the league?
Why didn't you invite me five
years or 10 years? They said, well,
we realize that you,
you broke the color barrier and we'd
like you to come to Chicago. So the, um,
my wife and I went to Chicago and I
had a reunited with the players that I
hadn't seen in 30 years. So we're
sitting in, sitting at a table,
she did for 10 and my wife wanted to a
glass of wine and there wasn't any on the
table. So I said, well, I'll
go to the bar and get one.
So I walk out to the
bar and the buyer was,
it was about 30 feet long and I walk up
and I asked the bartender a glass of red
wine, please. Now who comes beside me?
Is this a gentlemen I had
just about to say his name?
But this gentleman I had the
altercation with, and, uh, he, you know,
he's tall and he looks down and he
says, hello, are you, what's going on?
And I look not too bad. And I said, well,
let's get it on because I was
ready to go after 30 years.
I had his number and I said,
let's get it on here. But he, uh,
he went this way and I, and
I went that way. We never,
we never met again, but that,
that was about the only one.
The only time,
well that's good to hear,
cause under the circumstances I can
imagine that over the course of time, uh,
you could have had a number of different
incidents like that. And so, you know,
this is a story certainly of perseverance,
patience and evolution.
Uh, and as a function of that, let's,
let's kind of move on and speak to the
answer and for a little bit. Uh, you know,
interestingly enough,
there wasn't another black hockey
player after Mr [inaudible] until 1974.
That's quite a bit of time.
Right.
And certainly you didn't start playing
in 1974 but was born in 74 [inaudible]
want to get your perspective right.
Um,
as a black hockey player who had a
successful career, uh, you know, what,
in listening to those types of stories,
how the league from your eyes may
have kind of evolved over time and,
and what your experience in the league
was like in, in juxtaposition to that.
And maybe some of the things
you've noticed as it's,
as it's evolved over time
and it's definitely evolved.
I mean I know from when Willie played
too, when I played, it's come a long way.
Like society in general has come a long
way and I will say that Sports Mirror
society and vice versa.
But when I was coming up and
playing the national hockey league,
there wasn't very many of us playing.
I mean it's,
fortunately Kwame is talk about Evanston.
Our team at Edmonton,
we had a lot of black players in our team.
It happened to him.
Good Shawn Brown walking gauge myself,
George will rack.
And that's kind of how I was used to
playing hockey in Toronto because,
and I'm from Toronto and
everyone plays hockey as a kid.
It doesn't matter what color you are,
what your background is.
My parents were Beijing from Barbados,
so it was hard enough to convince them
to let me play hockey. My parents,
you know, ice, what you find ice in your
drinks. Like that's where you find nice.
So that's what I had to
overcome to allow them to allow,
let them let me play hockey.
But I was in another black player
playing on my team and of hockey,
so it wasn't a big deal.
And so I went to high school and then I
went to high school and hockey became a
quote unquote white sport, which blew
my mind cause I played basketball,
I played baseball,
I played every other sport under the sun,
actually went to Michigan State
to play hockey and baseball.
And I played everything under the sun.
But I got to high school and the hockey
wasn't cool again with my black friends
and it didn't really register with me
because I guess my parents said I'm
stubborn and I don't really care.
People say people think so.
I just kept it moving.
I didn't really listen to my friends
were saying and I went to Michigan State
and reporters said to me one time,
he was like,
ants and how does it feel being a black
hockey player? I sat and looked at him.
I was like, well, I don't know how
it feel to be a white hockey player,
so I couldn't tell like that's who I am.
That's me and I've never thought
about it any differently.
But coming to the league,
the really wasn't for myself personally.
There wasn't any situations where I had
any differences with my fellow teammates
because I was black and there were white.
Like when my best friends,
Johnny Nina [inaudible] finished guy
could look toy more different than myself.
Okay. Finish. She's from the north. My
parents are Caribbean or from Toronto.
I'm black, he's white and he loves
heavy metal. I Love Dance Hall.
Reggae music and hip hop and we'd always
arguing with the drive to the rink all
the time and Evans him because he'd have
his Metallica blaring and I come in,
I try to change the station
and he come into my truck,
I've got Buju Banton played or Jay z
or or or or Tupac or someone playing.
But eventually as we
developed our friendship,
we became to appreciate
each other's differences.
So there's times now there's
like Metallica playing in
my car and I'll turn it
up. My kids like what in the
world? He listened to Dan,
I was like, that's a ghost.
He said,
listen to.
So I listened to it now
too and I appreciate it and
he sends me text messages
all the time saying, well hey, listen
to us, listen to a reggae song.
It was like we're in Finland,
they play Reagan.
But that was the cool
thing about playing hockey.
Like we all had our differences.
We might not have interacted with each
other on that level or we might not have,
if we never played the game of hockey.
You have to be able to come together
and play at the highest level.
I mean this is a beautiful thing.
Let's talk about that a little bit
more for a second. Right? So you know,
having played in the league,
right,
but somebody who was clearly
talented in other sports, right.
And we see a lot of times these days
are athletes that could easily play a
number of different,
what would be your pitch for a young
brother coming up who was trying to figure
out whether he wanted to
go baseball, football, just
making it up, right? Or hockey.
I'm like,
well what would your pitch to say?
I think Kwame said it best and he
was like, you have to come to a game.
You need to go there and
experience it live to see the
size, the speed, the skill,
the athleticism, the hand eye
coordination that players need to play,
the reflexes to play the game at that
level. That's what will draw you in.
Like I love playing basketball.
Like there was no better feeling than
Dunkin on somebody when I play basketball.
Like I've loved it. But scoring a
goal had that same exact emotion.
That same feeling though brought energy,
you know,
hitting a baseball out of the park. I
love that feeling. But you score a goal,
same exact thing, jumping into
the glass. That's pure emotion.
I couldn't find that in any other sport.
So I would tell people,
and I tell kids in particular,
go to a game or watch a game.
Once you go to a hockey game, like you're
hooked. I mean, now you've got HDTV.
So it's way better than standard def.
So you could find out where the puck is.
And I tell if hockey fans
will atomic don't fall.
The puck fall the fall of the game.
When you follow the flow of the game,
the puck's gonna find you. Absolutely.
And that's a great answer. Um,
and a question for the,
for the three of you and then we'll,
we'll transition to Jessica here.
But um,
having been most recently in the league,
it's,
and can you please explain to folks what
a line is and beyond that kind of your
prediction on when there may
be a first all black pop.
So we almost came close to them and
say, no, it was myself, Lake George.
We'd always petition our coach and Craig
McTavish is our coaching wanna say Mac
let us play together and we have
Brownie Shawn Brown defense,
let Brownie play forward.
This one shifts.
We could down like the old
brother live speaking in brother.
When I was in Vancouver a few years ago
when I played my call my last couple of
years in the league and I had myself
from the sateen twins and that was our
nickname, the bro the line because
Dan and Hanks, the Dean and myself,
I think you're gonna see it eventually.
I mean there's just gonna be a time
when you're going to see enough players
playing on a team where they're going
to come together and form an all black
line.
Like I think it's one of the amount of
time when you see that coming once the
number of years, five years,
I would say five years or so.
I mean it has to start more
at the grassroots level
that we're seeing that right
now you're seeing kids coming up now
playing grass talky and once those numbers
start to increase your base increases
because when you're playing in the NHL
levels, it's a pyramid. So you
have the best of the best playing.
But if your base is a lot wider than that
pyramid up top gets a little wider as
well.
Right. Well that's a great segue
actually to talking with Jessica and,
and finding out a little bit more about
what the NHL is doing as it relates to
this. Um, NHL, full
transparency, one of the,
one of the later professional
leagues to integrate. Um,
but doing some of the research for this,
I was, I was pleasantly surprised, um,
at just the amount of kind of operational
work that has gone into diversity
within the league and continues. I
mean, I, I read a little bit about, uh,
they're being kind of a
mandatory diversity training
pre seasoned for folks that
come into the league. Uh, and certainly
the work that you're doing with, um,
hockey is for everyone. Um, and you know,
having been from growing up in Flatbush
Brooklyn, I'm sure that you've been,
you've grown up in,
in are aware of very diverse places
and have been in diverse situations and
clearly your job at the national hockey
league continues to perpetuate that.
Can you tell us a little bit about um,
the why you guys are doing the things
that you're doing and give us a sense of,
of, of how, by the way, yes.
Black history month is a, is a,
is a time of frame that we can shine the
light on the things that you're doing,
but uh,
how these things are happening year round.
Sure. Thank you. And on behalf of
the NHL, thank you for hosting this.
We talk a lot about reaching new audiences
and so this is a great opportunity
for us and really appreciate it.
Um, before I answer your question,
I just have to say I'm
hearing Anson Story, um,
really hits home for me.
It's the reason that I do what I do.
It's the reason that I always
wanted to work in sports.
The idea and the platform that sports
brings people together is what inspired me
to want to work in sports.
From my 16 year old,
uh, birthday, my family
took me to a hockey game.
I had never been to a hockey game.
My brother was a football player. Um,
I was a cheerleader and had for basketball
and football games and grew up in a
very diverse community.
I went to public school and there was a
moment at this game where the magic of
the game really took over
and the energy in the stands,
but also on the, and the
islander scored. And, uh,
we were sitting right
behind a two gentlemen.
It was a kind of the story you were just
saying. A black and a white person, um,
who seem to not know each other and the
islander scored and they embraced and
they embraced enthusiastically. And I, um,
for those who know me know
I'm quite inquisitive, so,
and I'm not shy. So I, uh,
I tapped them on the shoulder
after the moment passed and I said,
do you guys know each other? And they
said, no. Are you season ticket holders?
Nope,
please help me understand this moment.
Like why I watched you embrace and cheer
and hug and high five and each other's
families.
And they said the moment of
that goal brought us together.
And at that moment I turned to my parents
or with me and said I need to work in
hockey. And that could have
probably happened in other
venues and other contexts.
But having grown up in a place that
was challenged with racial issues,
I was always very interested in how to
bridge gaps in our community in Brooklyn.
Um, and that moment was like,
well this is the path to do that.
This creates that unification,
that platform where all of the differences
strip away and the pure passion that
exists just brings them
together instantly.
And what I was always wondering is if
those two people saw each other outside of
that venue,
is there carry over that.
That was the thing that always sort of
fascinated me and still fascinates me
when I work on diversity initiatives and
the idea that sports is a place where
we can model that behavior.
And your story with your teammate
really hits home for me. Um,
and is there a carry over beyond
that person? So do you look at,
and does he look at people who are
different from him in a different way,
through a different lens after having
that experience where your mind was opened
to his world in his mind
was open to your world.
So that's just a had to share that
because I'd never heard that story.
And um, that's really what draws me to
what I do. But to answer your question,
the Nhl has been,
um,
and probably a lot of people don't
know it has been working on diversity
initiatives for more than 20 years.
Um,
we hired Willie in 1998 as
our diversity ambassador.
He has been traveling from city to city,
market to market,
inspiring the next generation of people,
but also hockey players to give our sport,
to try whether you're a
fan or a player. And, um,
when we think about why we do that and
we challenge ourselves as to the why,
um, I think there's really three
reasons. The first is that,
and the commissioner always says
this, it's the right thing to do. Um,
we believe in equality and we believe
that everybody should have access to our
sport. And um, so we always do it
because it's the right thing to do.
And the values of sport really
perpetuate that and make that authentic.
And when you see it in the people who
have played our sport and you hear her
aunt's in and you hear Willie, and
really if you know, hockey players,
whether they're playing at the highest
level or even in a grassroots program,
hockey players are unique in that they
have these values that are all about
teamwork and humility and resilience and
hard work and sacrifice and dedication.
And it really creates
an environment where we,
we say with our partners, if you
can play, you can play, you know,
if you can contribute as a member of
our team, we want you on our team.
And, uh, we were actually
talking earlier and,
and both Willie and ants
and have both said, um,
although they experienced racial slurs
from fans and definitely from posing
players among their teammates,
they didn't experience that. Um,
and that's because our sport is really
all about what you bring to the table.
So the culture of our sport.
The second thing is that
we know particularly today
more than ever before and
even for the last five or 10 years,
there's a demographic shift happening
in North America and we want to be
relevant. We want to bring
new audiences into our game.
And so from a hockey is
where everyone perspective,
this is in addition to
being black history month,
also hockey's for everyone month,
which is a month where we shine a
light on all of the diversity inclusion
activities, initiatives, partnerships,
community engagement, um,
that all of our teams and the League
do of course they do that year round
through grassroots programming and boys
and girls club support and all kinds of
other outreach into diverse communities.
But February is a time where we,
where we celebrate that. So, um, again,
the second reason is really just to
introduce our game to new audiences.
And then the third is kind of going
back to what everyone was just talking
about,
which is we need to increase the
diversity and the pipeline into our game.
And so we have 26 hockey's for everyone
programs across north North America,
um, that bring tens of
thousands of kids into our game.
We're working on strategies to help them,
um,
to transition into competitive hockey
because playing the game at a recreational
level is really important.
Um,
and we want people to be able
to do it on a casual basis,
but if we want to change the demographic
of who's playing on the NHL on our
stage, and we all know the saying, you
have to see it to want to be it true.
Um, we need to find ways to help people
to transition to elite hockey who looked
different from our traditional
population of players. So, um,
I would say those are kind of the
three for the reasons of the why.
That's great reasons,
great reasons.
And it really shines a light
on the uniqueness of the
sport and what you all are
doing in, in these stories
really give context, uh,
around, around all of it and, and make
it, make it real. And for me personally,
um, you know, call me the
work that you've done, uh,
has really opened up my world to,
to the sport in a way that I
could have never imagined. Um,
and has gotten me interested. I
mean, I've been to one hockey game.
I will tell you the truth.
I've been the one professional hockey
game and this everything you said it was,
I mean it's
very large individuals who have grace
and talent and there's a lot of beauty in
the sport when you really get the
opportunity to, um, to view it live.
Um, and now to really kind of understand
the framework and the tapestry that is
behind it all really makes it so more,
so much more meaning, so meaningful.
So I thank you for bringing that to
light and please like kind of in our last
minute or so before we open it
up to questions on the floor,
very interested in understanding
what might be next from you.
Oh, in this world. You know, I
really, uh, it's, it's weird. I don't,
I don't know what's next,
but I know my passion lies
in hockey and seeing it grow.
Um, you know, I've been very
fortunate. Like you got to understand,
like when I left my job in radio,
I didn't know what I was going to do.
I had no source of income.
I just felt like I need
to be with these people.
I need to be with this group of people
from the Ahl to help grow the game.
And I kind of use, I
figured I was like, okay,
well how do you put in a resume?
Why don't you make a film?
Why don't you show them that you want to
be a part of this and you want to help
it grow.
And you know,
I just been fortunate to work with
Jessica like last year they had me on the
road showing the film and, and, and,
and, uh, talking about it. And I want to,
what I want to do next is I want to help
grow the game by telling stories and
doing whatever I can to get people in the
stands. Because I, you know, like I said,
like we say, you know, get
them into the arena. You know,
I always sit back and think, what if
Shaquille Neil's parents that play hockey,
what of Coby Brian's parents said,
play hockey?
What of Lebron James'
parents to play hockey?
And there's those kids
are out there right now.
And for the black community I feel
we sometimes put ourselves in a box.
We say, this is what we do and this
is what we don't do. When I grew up,
hockey was the white boy sport and I was
one of those kids who put myself in a
box. And because my friends were
black and they listen to hip hop,
I just did what they did. But I loved
this game of hockey, but I felt like,
oh well, you know, I guess that's
what the white boys to play.
Then the white friends that I had said,
well blacks don't play,
it's too cold or your ankles
are too short or small.
All these idiotic uh, stereotypes.
And I just like, okay.
And then you have to argue with them. I
like, but I did had no context, you know,
I didn't have that ammunition to say no.
There's a Willie ovary, this Carnegie,
right there was a colored hockey league
of Nova Scotia that was around in the
1800 [inaudible].
The first professional sports
organization for blacks was hockey.
It wasn't basketball, it
wasn't football, it was hockey.
Why are we not celebrating that?
And so putting that film together is
because of people like you that thought
didn't think twice of the game.
But if I showed it to you,
put some nice little hip hop in there
and he's got a lid, did not go unnoticed.
You know, I thought that it would
make someone go, oh wait a second.
Yeah, so you caught me, you caught
me, you know? Well listen folks,
we've got about eight or so minutes left.
I want to make sure that we open this up
to Googlers who are in the audience who
would like to ask some
questions to the esteemed panel.
We've got Mike's on, on both sides.
Uh, so if folks have questions,
please, let's, uh, let's get into it.
Okay.
Uh, we'll start on this side and then
we'll, we'll just go back and forth.
Okay.
Everyone, uh, my name is Chris.
Thanks so much for coming out
and speaking to us all today.
It's been a really awesome to hear.
So one of my questions is around, um,
kind of like the grassroots and ants and
like you were talking about Kinda like
the triangle and expanding that base.
Um,
it's great to hear about the grassroots
efforts, but I'm playing hockey myself.
A massive part of trying to go pro is
kind of facing that point when you were
maybe 15, 16, 17 years old,
you're going to leave home,
you're going to go to a city play for a
team where you don't really know anyone,
you maybe don't have a support system.
You've got to go play juniors to
try to get to that next level, um,
or private school for that matter.
So my thought is what is being done at
those areas to kind of offer that support
system for maybe,
you know,
the one kid of color who is
now out of, out of his, uh,
you know, comfort zone for the first
time and maybe facing some adversity. Um,
when it comes to that,
are there,
are there thoughts of support in the
junior ranks to try to progress people?
I take that back so I'm not sure,
but the junior ranks,
um, I just know with myself
what I do on a day to day basis,
a lot of times people reach out to me
when they hear there's a black hockey
player playing somewhere and they say,
Hey Anson,
do you mind talking to him or her and
give them a words of wisdom because kind
of like let them know exactly
what you went through.
Because a lot of times what I went through
is probably similar to what they are
going through or they're
going to probably, you know,
deal with at some point in their career.
So I'm not afraid to reach out to the
different players and it doesn't really
matter like a Kwame for example,
past me,
Joshua Ahow sangs number when he played
for the New York islanders and he's been
in the minors back and forth right now.
And Josh was a professional
at of junior kid,
but he went through some tough things
during training camp there with the
islanders and he slept in a,
he was getting this bad rap.
I think part of it was because
he was a black player, you know,
you looked at a little bit differently.
So I picked up the phone and I made
a phone call. It's like, Hey Josh,
we never met before but you're messing up.
And I didn't use that exact language.
But because we're here and
we appreciate that,
mess it up and I'll tell you why I didn't
go through what I went through or will,
he didn't go through what he went through
for you to come next and set us all
back.
You know what I mean?
So we're not to the point now where you
could screw up in everyone's gonna think
it's okay,
you're still black hockey player and
there were still the minority in the sport
and there isn't that many of us playing.
So you're going to make you do things
properly to set the next guy up the right
way. And I thought it went through
one year, one or the other.
I didn't hear from the
kid at all for four year.
And then I'm with Kwame and Willie at
a hockey in Harlem event last year and
this lady walks up to me and she
starts crying and you know, Brunette,
she's white just to let you know,
just put it in context for you.
And she's like crying and she's bawling.
I was like, what's up? And she's like,
I want to thank you. I said,
thank me for what she goes,
because you change someone's
life will change someone's life.
And I'm there with the deputy commissioner
of Bill Daley and build it and it's
like this lady lake, which handles
lady. And I was like, I have,
we met before and she's like, we haven't
met before. I was like, so what's,
how do like put this together for me?
And she's like, I'm Joshua his mother.
And I was like, oh, okay. And she's
like, he didn't call you back.
I know that.
But what you said to him really made a
huge impact and you didn't have to reach
out to him, but we appreciate
you reaching out and you know,
passing on what you had to
say to him and now he gets it.
So I think it's responsibility for people
like myself and people that are still
involved with the game that we see
Willy doing on a day to day basis with
hockey's for everybody travels around,
he reaches out and touches,
leads these kids.
But I think it's my responsibility as a
former pro now on national TV with NBC
or Msg to reach out to these people in
these kids as well and letting them know
what I see to make their
life a little bit easier.
And Jessica, do you have any,
oh, so just to piggyback on
what he said, um, you know,
one of the things like with
um, with Jayden, um, you know,
when he was in that draft year,
I would take him when I was doing
interviews and stuff like that,
I would take him to meet these guys
because I always thought that that's what
they need, that support
system. Mike Morrison,
who was the second black athlete to play
in the NHL got in there and he was 18
years old and he was told it to be the,
that black superstar that was going to
come out there playing Washington DC
because Washington DC at that
time was predominantly black,
but it didn't go the way we all wanted it.
And he just kept going down
and going down Gannaway angels.
And the one thing he used to tell me
was there was no support system for me.
So if he had other black athletes
that he could talk to, Lena,
you only had one other black player
that played within bill Riley,
but it was just the two of them.
But if he had that support system,
things would have changed for them.
So I think that's one of the things that,
you know, Anson and Kevin Weeks do.
And I, I hope that, you know, the,
the league will encourage
more of them to do is,
which is to reach out to these young
guys and just say, hello, how you doing?
How's your game going? You know, what
are you going through? What do you need?
Let's talk.
Because that's the way it's going to grow.
Because sometimes these young
black players in these small areas,
they feel alone. And one lastly, when
I, when the film debuted on the, uh,
the NHL Network, I got
messages, text messages, um,
tweets from parents saying that they
sat down with the kids to watch the film
and their kid wanted to get back out
there and play because they thought they
were alone. They thought they were
going through this on their own.
But when they saw the film and they saw
what ants in and William all these guys
went through, they said, oh,
okay. They persevere. It,
I can persevere through
adversity and quickly, uh,
Jessica from an NHL
institutional perspective.
Yeah, no, I'll take a couple
more questions. I think. Yeah,
I have a little bit more.
I'll be,
I'll be brief.
I think there's extra challenges
for minority groups for sure.
But the challenges that you're identifying
are challenges for everyone, right?
I mean,
it's hard for everybody to leave home.
Definitely more so when you're
from a minority population and you,
you feel that extra pressure.
Um,
I'll just say from an NHL
institutional perspective,
we've been meeting for the last three
years with all the governing bodies to
talk about ways to open up
pathways to the NHL. Um,
so hopefully there'll be more to come.
We actually announced in September our
declaration of principles as a product of
those conversations,
which is a stake in the ground value
statement that 17 leading hockey
organizations signed on to.
It's kind of like our mission statement,
which is that hockey is
more than a game and hot,
the benefit that hockey gives you is to
build character or life skills and all
about breaking down barriers. So, um,
those discussions kind of range from
grassroots all the way up through juniors
all the way up to minors,
NHL, international. So, um,
hopefully there'll be more to come on
ways that we can increase all those
pathways to the NHL.
Fantastic.
I want to get everybody in a,
I think we started just a little bit
late so maybe they'll grant us a couple
more minutes to,
to get through.
But we'll go over here and then we'll
come back over here and then we'll,
we'll wrap up.
Hi. Thank you all so much
for coming again. Um,
in addition to growing our player base,
in terms of diversity,
I think we also as hockey fans want to
grow our fan base in terms of diversity.
And so I'd be interested in hearing the
panel's opinion on what things we should
be doing is hockey fans and as the hockey
community to make ourselves, you know,
I'm, I'm more open
environment, uh, for that.
I think if you know somebody in the
minority community that's never been to
encourage them to go to a
game, I would, you know,
I think that's one of the best
thing to do is to say, Hey,
come to a game with me and just give
it a try. They might be like, ah,
it's too cold. Just be like,
listen, put on a jacket,
let's go and just get them into an
arena and just expose them to the game.
And it doesn't even have
to be a professional game.
It could be a minor league
game cause you know,
Games are games and
they're just fun to watch.
I'll say from a policy perspective,
we talk a lot at the league level about
creating an inclusive environment. So, um,
I think part of that is us making sure
we have proper fan code of conduct and
that everybody's on board as to what
is and isn't appropriate behavior.
But I always say it's also the fans
job to create in it peer to peer
accountability.
So when I'm in the stands,
even with my family and I
hear inappropriate language,
I'll say something to them like,
we don't want that in our arena.
And um, you can even see NHL
teams during hockey's for Vermont.
Actually yesterday the Pittsburgh Penguins
responded to some negative on social
and said, you know, we don't, we don't
want that in our game. And so, um,
the louder and more engaged
the positive message is,
the more those people who are negative
and creating and not inclusive
environment will quiet down and go away.
And that'll open up the pathways for
more nontraditional audience to enjoy our
game.
Thank you.
So
I think it's really outrageous that
willy is not in the hockey hall of fame.
What can we do to change that?
Be Late to the flight right
now cause we've already, we're,
we're kind of working behind the scenes.
I know several different
guys that are on the, the,
the panel that decides who gets in,
oh I've put the bug in Luke robotize zero
bottle Kenzie David poile like I'm all
over these guys nonstop because yeah,
you know Willie is a living legend and
I know not only what he's done for my
crew to allow me to put
the national hockey league,
but also other points like you see these
other superstars from around the world.
Alex Ovechkin will embrace Willy O'ree
and we talk about hockey's for everyone.
It's not just minority players, it's
European floors, finished player,
Swedish players,
Russian players.
There was a time when European players
weren't accepted in the national hockey
league. You heard terms like
chicken, Swede or Russians,
you can't count in the more.
Finns have no clue what they're
doing over there on the ice.
But part of what willy does and breaking
down barriers is letting people know
that we could all play this game.
So absolutely he can be a builder since
1998 one over 120,000 kids Willie's
been, you know, engage with and
had conversations with them,
encouraging them to play hockey and life
lessons that come around and playing
hockey. If that's not a builder. Yeah.
I don't know what it is. Yeah. I'm sold.
We'll take a
take one more question and then we'll,
we'll wrap up.
Thank you all so much for
coming to speak here. Um,
so this Wednesday I went to a talk on
the future of skating in New York and
someone there asked a question, um, um,
about why in in New York City,
the home of three NHL franchises and
the NHL itself that the state of,
of skating and playing hockey in
general is so dismal. Hmm. Um, you know,
part of why it's so hard
to get into hockey is that
it's hideously expensive and
it's hard to get ice time. And,
uh, people in New York who, um,
want to play hockey, um, if they get
serious about it, they leave. Um,
I was just wondering what you
all had to say about that.
Basketball is a New York is a
basketball state. Uh, I think,
um, you know, I not sure
what different communities
are doing,
but I think you have to look at it as
stages and I think you have to go into
these communities, get them interested
in, you know, something else. Yeah.
It's basically a street
hockey and ball hockey.
And once you start to attract kids and,
and,
and the communities and to
see how much fun that is,
it will transition to wanting to skate.
And then parents and families in these
communities are going to try to position
a petition to get these arenas going.
So I think that's one way of doing it,
you know, and hopefully
that, you know, it will grow.
You're seeing a lot of organizations
now to building arenas on the respective
cities. That's important that I'll come
with lowering the cost of playing hockey.
Uh, being from Toronto, there's a rink
every block like Starbucks here basically.
It's not that expensive,
but I hear what you're saying about um,
unlimited ice time here in New York City.
I think everything in New York in
general is just expensive period.
But having additional rinks in,
a lot of these organizations
are doing that right now.
And you're asking about trying to get
nontraditional fans to get engaged.
Kwame is talking about maybe
have them come to games,
but also just getting to try skating,
just try skating and seeing how difficult
it is to get up and down the ice.
And I've got two daughters, nine
11, and they could skate now,
but the first time they figured out how
to skate and not actually fall on their
butts, they're like, wow,
this is amazing. Yeah.
And then I brought him to a hockey game
that took of the whole different level
because they're like, well,
okay, skating is tough,
but now these guys are
doing this on the ice. Well,
someone's going to take their head off
at the same time, like out of control.
So I think the combination of
all those things, I mean you're,
you're seeing Adidas now, they're, they're
getting involved with Columbia's talk.
Most street hockey.
I think that's probably the lowest level.
And we start looking at trying to
get the stick in kids' hands. Yeah.
Stick sticking a ball.
And once you have that
feeling of playing the game,
then you want to take it the next level.
Because I didn't start playing
hockey is as an ice skater,
I started ball hockey player.
I played street hockey and try
like I was a street hockey wizard.
One of my friends were like, oh you
can't skate. And I had no come back.
Then I was like,
you're right.
But then I figured out how to
skate and then I could, you know,
start chirping back. Yeah. So I learned
from a young age how important skating it.
So I think skating and just playing ball
hockey or probably one of the keys to
that entry level way into figuring out
if you want to play the game of hockey or
not.
I'll just share two things.
First you'd be surprised at how many NHL
players didn't start playing ice hockey.
They played street hockey,
roller hockey. Um, it,
it's actually quite staggering
when you, when you look at it. Um,
I think in addition to providing
access to alternative forms of game,
there needs to be a culture shift in terms
of allowing those players who are not
playing ice hockey and not playing a lead
hockey to define themselves as hockey
players. So if you play street hockey
and someone says, do you play hockey?
I want those people to say, yeah, I
play hockey because hockey is hockey.
And so I think we're trying to do a lot
more in terms of inclusive messaging on
everyone who plays hockey is
part of the hockey family.
So that those people who are asked like,
do you play hockey? Are you a hockey fan?
And they play in their, in their garage
or in their driveway can say, yeah,
I'm a hockey player. I think the
second thing is in terms of, um,
access to ice is that the nhls invested
a lot of resources in intro to the game,
learn to play programs for ages five
to nine with the idea that there was a
little bit of a chicken and an egg
scenario where if you do, we need,
we were just talking about it up
there about building rinks. Well,
who's gonna play in them?
Because our,
our programs oversubscribed supply and
demand from an economic perspective.
And you're talking about
public private partnerships.
What are they going to invest in there?
They want to,
they want to benefit their communities.
So we need to show the demand and in
order to show the demand we need to,
we need to expand the
funnel at the bottom.
And so we're really doubling down on that
five to nine age range so that we can
show that demand in the
community at a young age.
And that hopefully will spur
more investment in facilities,
which will help break down barriers from
an infrastructure perspective. Awesome.
Uh, well, listen folks, I hope that, uh,
all of you are as enlightened as I am
after today's discussion and certainly
after having seen the documentary, if you
haven't seen it, make sure that you do.
It's been great to have
you all take the time that,
so that we could share
in your experiences,
which have been very meaningful and
heartfelt to me and certainly from an NHL
standpoint,
really giving us a window and transparency
into all the great things that you
guys are doing that continue to
grow and diversify the sport.
Are you a hockey fan now?
I'm a hockey fan. I promise. I
will thank all of our panelists.
Thank you all very much.
Thank you.
Thanks everyone for coming.